.
>>NN IER DC NIC ROBERUS.
I  T TO R VIEWERS OR CINI KNOW R
COUPLE LINESLLY  ARTICLE YOU JUM
WAS REALL.
LE G LINES WU WROTE.
THOF COVERINI LEE INSPAIR.
BRIGHT HOPE MANY ONC
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN ISN'T
JUG UKBUT
NATIONS,G SS TSE.AIN YOUR THOS ,
>>R HE
PUTIN DOWN O HALS
W
AE
E TION, MANY OF DON'T SUPPORT PN
DON'T SUPPORT THWATHEY'RFER THE
SEQUENCES.
HE'S TOLD HIOLAR
GETTING SANCCHSEIZEDHEEM TO SUC
'S MADE E SITUATION,  WHO NTED O
THABSOLUTEN WAY
HAS GONE TO AL
PRETEXT AN PUSH  ABSOLUTELY
STE OF.T --YOU'RE
GETCHING IT HAPPEN, THAT'S WHAT
>> BECAUSE YOU WERE BACK
INF VIET UNION.
THVIMBHE
WERE UPBEAAT
THGSBRAND- W SENSE, AN --  SO.SE
DDFA
IDN.
SO U RTTHAT
AT THAT TIME YOU HAD TA COUNTRY
WANTED TATE TO THEORWARD AEC PUN
COMES TOGES,
ALIGNMENT TOWARD APEGRATINE
ID THAWRD HE'S REVSED TRIED TO E
INVASIONS
IN UKRAINE, AN I,
US MP  RUSSIA ISE  PUTINTHAT I .
AND THATTHMO THETRIMENT OFHE VA
DETRIMENT OFPL U RIGHT NOW.
I ORIGINWELL HE'TH
ALON DTHMEA.-- DED TO GO  OF E -
CAS SE TO ME I ME, AS WELL.
MEUR GET WHAT WEWA W.TO NEEDS T,
NEEDS TOBACK TIT
NEEDS TOINE BECOMIMEK PEOPLE THA
JUST PUTIN INAT
HE TABLE
WOUHE'S BECE DETERMINED.
LOOKG
FORWARD, IERRITORY, CITIES,
A TOWN
GOING  STOP, AND HOW DO YOU E MW
GET EN TO LET GO OTHEM BACK KRU.
HOW DO WE HOGEPUTICKAND I T IG.
E WHERE THATEC
IS.>> YOU WERE DOGREAREPORTING N
TY WAS DOING GREAT
REOSYBODY HABAFLED,
THSSN INVASI OINE
THEY COULD WIND UPN JAIL
15EA.T LIKE F THE MN
MOSCOW RIGHT N WAS A THE
OF THE  YOU
WHERE THE PROTTSE
ENANTO STA SHOULDER
TO SHOULDE PROERELBOW TOLBOW WH
WEREBERUTHE RSTHAT'SN YOU'RETHA
ISS
A STATE E HE CAN
DE T ARE GOING TO BE, E APPARAT
S. VERY MUOOKING-
SORDE WORLD WAR
MB W FROM THE
E E RULEUSG
THERE IS A SYSTEA ENBOE THATLOWM
CHN.'VE BEEN DOINGZI
ING FOT JUSTALL OFHESE YEA, GOG
BACK 30 YEARS TOGETHER.
WE
ULF WAR ON
WEU DOIN